Speaker 1: This is super interesting. Many of you
know about Republican Congressman Kevin McCarthy
now Kevin McCarthy is a guy who back around the
Trump riots, was speaking regularly not only with
Donald Trump but with other people in that circle.
And CNN has unearthed audio of Kevin McCarthy
saying I spoke to Trump, and Trump admitted he
has some responsibility for the riots to me.
Now, why is this relevant? It's relevant because
for the last year plus now, year in two weeks,
almost to the day Donald Trump and people around
him have been denying that Trump had anything to
do with what ultimately took place and or saying
it was peaceful and or saying the violence was
antifa. So all of those different things conflict.
Some of them cancel each other out doesn't matter.
The point is, they've gone out of their way to
say, Trump. There's no responsibility here for
Trump whatsoever, for what happened on January
6th and yet. And yet, CNN unearths audio of Kevin
McCarthy saying Trump admitted responsibility
for the riot. CNN's K File resurfaced the top
House Republicans comments to a California radio
station days after the Jan. six insurrection.
Let's just listen to the audio. Take a
listen to exactly what Kevin McCarthy said.
Speaker 3: I say he has a responsibility.
He told me personally that he does have some
responsibility. I think a lot of people do what I
proposed, which I think history will say I'm right
because it's the right thing to do. I believe have
a bipartisan commission and get all your facts
actually work through the grand jury to
find out at the end instead of determining
whether someone's guilty or not.
Speaker 1: Pretty. Wow. I mean, it's not
only a good idea to have a special committee do
a special investigation while it's happening now,
and Republicans are essentially completely
opposed to it. But Kevin McCarthy clearly says,
I believe Trump has some responsibility. And Trump
admitted to me that he has some responsibility.
This has been completely buried now. Kevin
McCarthy was more recently asked about it.
He forgot guys he doesn't remember. Kevin
McCarthy says he doesn't remember the phone call
where Trump admitted some responsibility days
after January 6th. House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy told other Republicans in a phone
call that Trump claimed some responsibility
for the Capitol riot, according to CNN. But
during a news conference Thursday, McCarthy
said he couldn't recall the phone call. Here is
Kevin McCarthy asked about it. Check this out!
Speaker 2: Did you tell House Republicans
on a January 11 phone call that President
Trump told you? He agreed that he bore
some responsibility for January 6th,
as Chairman Thompson's letter indicates.
I'm not sure what call you're talking about.
Speaker 1: And then he goes on to a different
reporter. Now, notice the very specific language.
I don't know what call you are talking about.
That's a very different answer than I have never
said nor believed. Trump admitted responsibility,
nor is responsible. So if someone said to me. Did
you say that and I go, I don't know what phone
call you're talking about. It's not a denial.
Right. Sort of like if someone says, Hey,
did you um, did did you call and threaten
to steal pizza from a Pizza Hut? And I go, I
don't know what phone call you're referring to.
That's a very different answer. Then I've never
called Pizza Hut and threaten to steal pizza.
These are two very, very different reactions.
And Kevin McCarthy. Listen, if you have to guess
what the truth is, the truth is, at the time, it
wasn't yet clear that for a year, Trump and the
people around him would deny that he had anything
to do with the riot. So Kevin McCarthy said it in
early January, mid-January of 2021 and meant
it, and it was true. And now, in retrospect,
it would look very, very bad for McCarthy
to say this last year of Trump and everybody
around him pretending like he had nothing to
do with it. And there's nothing to see here.
Well, a year ago, Trump admitted to me that he
had some responsibility that would look very,
very bad for Trump, and it would probably put
Kevin McCarthy in the doghouse. So I believe
that Trump did say it. I believe McCarthy did
report it at the time, and now he's just lying.
And it's such a technical and specific
answer. I don't know what phone call you
are referring to is a world away from. I've never
said it because Trump never said it to me, and I
don't believe that he bears any responsibility.
Those are dramatically different things